printing in progress
please stand clear
printing printing
printing assembling navigation system
energizing flux capacitor installing
artificial intelligence
your vehicle is ready
[Music]
for a hundred years we've been making
vehicles pretty much the same way
the assembly line and it's efficient a
large modern factory can roll
out thousands of vehicles per day but it
isn't very flexible when it comes to
changing designs very often
[Music]
here in knoxville tennessee a company
called local motors is taking a
different approach
have they discovered the way of the car
making future
that's what i'm here to find out
[Music]
so is this the biggest 3d printer in the
world as far as i know
yes as of this moment this is the
world's largest commercial
large-scale additive manufacturing
machine can you explain how something's
actually made with this machine
yeah certainly whatever it is that you
want to make what we do is put it into a
program
that's the instruction set that tells
the machine what to do and where to go
and based on that pattern we deposit
material
and in a layer by layer fashion you
start building up your shape
locomotors prints the chassis of its
vehicles out of a composite material
that's about as hard as a traditional
metal car body once it cools
and then if you really want it to be
very precise then you can come back in
and you can machine it you can take that
material off and get those
precise edges those hard contours and
shapes
about how long does something take to
make something like a vehicle chassis
takes about nine hours
stick on a few non-3d printed items like
wheels and headlights
and the result is one of the company's
sleek looking all-electric cars
the company gets its vehicle designs
through a sort of crowdsourcing process
in which engineers from all around the
world submit designs and competition for
cash prizes
and royalties on the finished car so if
i had a design i wanted to bring and
have you guys print like how detailed
does that design need to be
you just need the basic cad model your
computer aided design
and we can work from there we can take
this one machine and we can change what
it produces
very easily because that's just done in
a computer file
when i hear 3d printer i usually think
about the makerbot style desktop
machines that were all the rage in the
early 2010s when it seemed like everyone
was going to have a 3d printer in their
house within a few years
in reality though the major advances in
adoption and 3d printing have been
happening behind the scenes
used for applications ranging from
building houses in developing countries
to printing living human tissue
it's morphed into a 10 billion dollar
industry that's projected to more than
triple by 2024
but back in 2014 when local motor ceo
jay rogers first started trying to 3d
print entire cars
things were a little different 3d
printing had been used to make
individual car parts
but printing an entire car body was
another question entirely
there were far many more naysayers than
there were
supporters people who said it can't be
done or it shouldn't be done
no one had ever done it nothing to my
knowledge had ever been done at that
scale right so it was less about the
fact that it was a car
more about the fact that it was larger
and 3d printed
faced with a daunting engineering
challenge local motors reached out to
oak ridge national laboratory
a knoxville based government facility
that was instrumental in the creation of
the first atomic bomb
they were developing giant 3d printers
and they agreed to help local motors
make the first
3d printed car ever
live at an international trade show in
full public view
we said let's 3d print the first vehicle
in the world and assemble it and drive
it off the show floor right there that
was the goal
it was very nervous making because we
were getting close by the time we went
to the show
but we were still failing in some of the
prints and so
we were very nervous that we would get
to the show and fail
how did it go it was successful
[Applause]
and this is the result lestrade
how you doing driving by the way i love
this it's pretty simple right man it's
like second nature
it's smooth i mean it's somewhere in
between a golf cart and like a
a dune buggy you know i mean it's nimble
you're so low to the ground that you
just feel very stable
yeah we had limitations so like our roll
bar that's back here as you'll note it's
a little shorter than my head because
the printer wasn't at the time
capable to go up higher what would you
say the top speed is of this
configuration
i think this configuration should be 25
miles an hour
i don't know what would you say does it
feel like we're zipping along i feel
like we could
hit about 25 yeah it feels about right
maybe on a downhill 30 yeah
the strategy proved that a 3d printed
car was possible
but as a car there wasn't much to it and
it's never really been commercialized
the company's first 3d printed
production vehicle the ollie
is a bit more interesting ollie is
a electric connected self-driving
3d printed vehicle it's a cute little
box
in japanese it would be called a hakko
and it is meant
to driverlessly deliver people to places
around the campus a few ollies have
already made it out into the world like
here at national harbor
just outside washington dc
they can run completely autonomously on
a fixed route though a human still rides
along to take over when the ai can't
figure out exactly what to do
so right now are we in autonomous mode
no no we're in autonomous mode so right
now we're in a geofence
fixed route kind of environment in the
future we could
do uh dynamic routing where people could
actually
call the alley just similar to an uber
or
lyft what happens if like someone steps
into the middle of the
crosswalk or something yeah so obviously
if the vehicle perceives the
pedestrian or cyclist stepping in the
vehicle will stop
so for example right now it just saw
that vehicle and it gave it the right of
way
right so it understands what obstacles
are there
and then how to avoid them
it's amazing how quickly it feels like
totally natural like i just don't even
think about it anymore you know you
haven't turned around the whole time
right haven't you checked the driver
like
he's still awake doesn't matter right
yes do you like driving i mean would you
miss it if it all became autonomous
i think there is a set of people that
will always want to drive but i think in
the future
you will have vehicles that are allowed
to be driven
on certain tracks for specially licensed
and trained people and then the rest of
us
will all drive in a connected automated
shared
mobility solution
whether you think that future sounds
amazing or appalling
it's probably the general direction
things are headed
the trickier question is what role 3d
printing plays in that future
for local motors the main advantage is
that it makes developing and retooling
vehicles much faster than before
traditional manufacturing is five to
seven years from a decision
to build a vehicle to see the first
product come out we are 12 months total
to a sellable product so we are at a
minimum we're five times faster
that increased speed means local motors
could update or customize its vehicles
much more easily than a traditional car
maker can
in fact they already have a ton of ideas
for future designs for the ollie
some of which are pretty unorthodox like
mobile grocery stores
mobile conference rooms post offices and
even a mobile podcast studio
and local motors isn't the only auto
company using 3d printing
it's been adopted by larger auto
manufacturers such as ford and bmw
where it's been used for prototyping new
parts and even creating discontinued
parts for classic cars
[Music]
it's come in particularly useful in
aviation too where companies like ge
and honeywell are using 3d printed parts
to reduce the weight of airplane engines
but before you get too excited 3d
printing isn't likely to replace
traditional factories anytime
soon there's still a major drawback
volume
what it doesn't do is things very
quickly so if i wanted to make a hundred
thousand of something
this probably wouldn't be my process
you'd want to
you know maybe scale and do something
else
add in the time it takes to assemble the
rest of the vehicle and you're looking
at only about one ollie per day from
this factory
the company plans to boost production by
building dozens more of these so-called
micro factories all over the world
but for now they only have this one in
knoxville
still there's an undeniable power and
the ability to make basically anything
you can imagine
in fact i've already started designing
my fantasy vehicle
so local motors when you're ready to
make me a flying car with afterburners
and let's say an espresso maker
give me a call i'll be waiting
[Music]
you